[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi grim Blitzer here the greatest
announcer of all time and star the most
outrageous sports game ever
Newton Football League you haven't heard
of it we'll sit back and let uncle grim
tell you all about Emma pills an
action-packed arcade-style football game
where monsters and Newtons compete on
the gridiron by racking up the most
points or racking up the kill count to
force a forfeit the AMF Hill has a
roster of acclaimed all-stars made up of
skeletal dead heads most resorts bruiser
box mutated humans and criminal area and
these guys can unleash some serious
carnage on the gridiron unlike other
games this one has less mayhem
oh it rocked him like a hurricane one
warm and fuzzy call your friend slugsy
but if you want to chain saws
we've gotta watch shotgun Gaston to M
appelle has 18 through some teams with
unique play field not unique like this I
mean like this
NFL delivers truly distinctive play
experiences on every single field which
are filled with diabolical trap and
hazard
that's logical get your morning buzz on
don't take my word for it here's what
the press is saying
so if you're tired of playing the same
game and looking for something new so
don't just sit there look at the screen
dummy you know you wanna so go get it
turn on to need
new football we we're putting the fun
back in football
[Music]